I love the game I like the money and the
money is certainly a method of keeping
school but I don't do things for money I
do things because I enjoy doing them
that will can sometimes commands late
into more money than you would have made
if you went just after the money never
ever give up you can change and you can
move around but never ever give up I
know people that are very smart they
went to the Wharton School of Finance
with me I know other people that aren't
as smart and those people are the top
people in industry today and the top
they just were tougher they didn't give
up and the smart ones had everything on
their plate that always come in with the
A+ on the tests and the good boards and
everything else but when they ran into
problems they didn't know how to solve
the problems like the guys that weren't
as good and it's very seldom that you
see something other than this happen
so never ever give up you just watch -
amazing clips from Donald Trump take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how to apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]